thank you for joining us for our hot
topics today we have we're very lucky to
have Professor Michael Lin from Stanford
Michael received his a B summa [ __ ] laude
in biochemistry from Harvard and he
followed that with a PhD in biological
and biomedical sciences also at Harvard
at the Medical School he also received
an MD degree from UCLA in 2004 dr. Lin
is currently a professor at Stanford
where he leads a research group
developing protein based tools for
imaging and controlling biomedical
processes he has a long string of awards
and to me most importantly he is the
author of what I consider as the most
viral slide deck on kovat 19 in in the
recent days Michael welcome welcome to
Cecil welcome to MIT welcome to the
College of Computing at MIT were eager
to learn from you please go ahead oh
great hello well thank you very much
danila
yeah thanks everyone for taking your
time to join yeah it's my pleasure it is
to share what's with you what I what
I've learned myself about the virus and
the and the disease in the last few
weeks so you know we're living through
unprecedented times nothing we've seen
nothing like this since perhaps the 1918
flu epidemic and so I think it's it's
useful for us to all learn the facts and
you know try to try to spread knowledge
about the disease so I'm gonna get
started and here in my powerpoint window
um so some of you have seen this slide
deck some of you have not and I
understand the slide deck I had made for
my own lab meeting to basically ease
anxiety among my lab members and use the
facts to try to you know try to put
together a plan of action and so I'm you
know I'm happy to share these facts with
you as well and I'll try to explain you
I'll try not to get too deep into the
biochemical details but hit the most
important points along the way so as
some of you have seen this is not a
pretty powerpoint I haven't had a time
to make it really glossy it's not like a
TED talk I'm not pushing a simple idea
there's just a lot of facts um but I
think it's only when you understand all
the facts together that things make
sense so we just could start with some
very general numbers to put some context
into the numbers we're gonna get into
shortly the total population that USA is
as close to some into 30,000 I've been
doing a lot of my calculations based on
numbers in California because it's just
easier for us to think about locally
that's about one-eighth of the USA 40
million people so you know the major
causes of death for young people in the
US are traffic accidents there's 30,000
per year in the USA about 3,000 for
California for older people it's
actually flu is a leading cause of death
on their 40,000 deaths a year it's never
really known how much but the range this
years is estimated between 22 and 55
thousand so how does have 40,000 about
5,000 there USA so for I'm sorry about
5,000 in California so for a population
of 40 million in California um you can
use this sort of number to give it get a
general idea of how lethal flu is if 25
percent of people got the flu virus and
only five percent 5,000 died that's a
infection fatality rate er or ifr of
0.05 percent um it's probably actually
more like 0.1% that is more like 12% of
the population might get the flu virus
in a given year because we have flu
shots so is everything okay you guys can
see the slides
Danijela okay yes everything is going
great thank you very much yes okay great
so we'll get right into you some quick
definitions you the disease is disease
name is coded 19 I think we have all
seen this term much more than we want
technically it refers to the disease not
virus in practice the term cases of
koban 19 are used to refer to having a
positive lab test whether or not you
have symptoms for reasons that are
partly political partly medical if you
just have the symptoms you know you're
not necessarily yet a kovat 19 case
because you could have for example a bad
case of food so you tend to wait for the
lab test result the w-h-o the World
Health Organization introduced a name
Cobin 19 after holding the world in
suspense for a few weeks see how
important it was to get the name right
and then when they announced the name
there was no name for the that was the
name for the disease but there was no
name for the virus and so everyone
started using coping 19 as the name for
the virus because it was no other name
given by who for it so this has led to
some confusion so a lot of people use
the term Kobe 19 you refer to the virus
I mean I guess that's fine in a popular
late point of view but technically it
actually makes a difference because when
we I'd like to talk about cases of the
disease and infection numbers based on
an estimate of the virus and so I try to
use the virus a different name for the
virus when possible I mean I personally
think of it 19 is a terrible name
because it stands for corona virus
disease 2019 and who says if you want to
talk about a virus you could call it the
Cobra 19 barbers but that would mean
corona virus disease 20:19 virus which
is a lot as a mouthful for saying
nothing it basically reveals that the
disease name is no informational value
so previously we had named diseases by
some sort of description as a disease so
SARS was called the SARS was named stars
because it was called um because it
stood for severe acute respiratory
syndrome and actually this this disease
is very similar to SARS both in
symptomology and in the in the in the
agents in the in the agent that causes
it so
the World Health Organization could have
just named this SARS - and that would
have been both accurate and descriptive
so what is the name of the virus it was
initially called 2019 and called that
stands for 2019 new coronavirus and was
given by some infectious disease
organization this hasn't been picked up
because it's a really hard term to
remember you don't usually think of
numbers when you think of naming things
so and I think it's also misleading
because it gives the impression that
this virus is actually novel it's not
particularly novel and I would say it's
the least novel of the new viruses we've
isolated and sequenced the most
interesting thing about it is that it's
not that novel and that's because it's
96% identical to the virus that causes
SARS in 2003 so in fact the name that
the biology biological name for it the
name for it sequence is SARS coronavirus
- or SARS code - so we'll use this name
throughout my presentation and I like
this name because it reminds us that
SARS Cove to the one reminds us that
source co2 is very similar to stars cold
one and so a lot of the things that
we've learned about the corona virus one
which came out in 2003 so almost 20
years ago um is very relevant to start
to predicting what would happen with
SARS co2 and kovat 19 so I would just
say if you haven't realized it yet I'm
not a big fan of how who has managed
this crisis but who who decided not to
name the virus SARS cough - for
precisely this reason because it made
people think of SARS they wanted to
obscure the relationship between the two
viruses they thought it was it would be
unfair to call the virus Tsarist called
q and to call the disease SARS - because
it would remind people about SARS
H I think that would have been a good
thing to do and as scientists it's
better to be clear about what you're
working with rather than trying to
create false distinctions so I call
Sarah's Cove tube
so what are coronaviruses what are so
scoffed - I don't have a picture I mean
I think you see many many e/m images
many illustrations of the virus like
other viruses it looks like a little
round ball with a little spike sticking
out of it from the molecular biology
point of view what's interesting
important to know is it's it's fully RNA
it doesn't go through a DNA phase and
that we're actually very familiar with
this class of viruses because they
account for 10 to 30% of the common code
and they're unusually stable for RNA
viruses so we were used to hearing the
RNA viruses mutate very quickly these
are these they are RNA viruses will
always be less stable than DNA viruses
but among RNA viruses Leasing to be
pretty stable for example the corner
virus oc4 t3 causes the common code it's
it was sequenced once in the 1960s it
was sequence from isolate from the 1960s
in a sequenced again from Iceland in
2001 and those only had two amino acid
differences six nucleotide differences
so that's pretty amazing as you've
probably heard there many corona viruses
and bats and they seem to hop easily
between species so they're they're quite
adaptable to a variety of mammalian
species so we had the Middle East
respiratory syndrome MERS virus that
hopped from camels to humans the
original stars virus hop from bats to
probably to civets and in humans and
then this one most likely came from bats
as well through some intermediate animal
and there's a bat virus is very closely
related to the SARS virus you can see
that in the bottom in the bottom yellow
in the bottom red arrow and I made this
point that the human code virus OSI 43
is very closely related to this Mouse
hepatitis virus actually what's not
shown here is there's also a Cal virus
it's very closely related to humans so
either humans or cows seem to have given
mice laboratory mice hepatitis
so um so how might you kill this virus
everyone wants to know how do you kill
it so it's an envelope virus there's a
thin plasma membrane that's only two
molecules of lipid wide so that's
actually really easy to kill anything
that would dissolve a lipid will kill
the virus that includes soaps or
detergents solvents organic solvents
like ethanol isopropanol I like to use
Windex which is detergents and bleach
will kill it is it just kills off
proteins and biological molecules so
it's also sensitive to temperature I
mean I well I should say that the
original stars were sensitive to
temperature so that the current stars
too is likely as well and there's some
numbers that you can look at for example
the bottom left this is a graph of of
how much tighter reduction you get with
different temperatures oh I left my
temperature numbers off that's actually
I think thirty seven thirty three and
twenty eight I'll have to put that back
on so and then the survival of the virus
depends on the surface so this is a
paper that was recently published a new
internal medicine on smooth surfaces
like steel and plastic it it's more it
survives or longer than on then on
porous materials like cardboard so that
means on paper towels or napkins this or
survival should be like whiteboard or
lower but also the viruses will get
trapped in these paper fibers so it's
not easy to get virus out of in napkins
for example and then it can be killed by
UV so the amount of UV in sunlight is
enough to kill probably is enough to
kill SARS coat Q by ninety percent after
about three hours at the current I could
I ask a question yes so I heard that the
virus can survive up to nine days the
data here does not take us to nine days
can you yeah the data here takes us to
three days so most headlines will say
bars can survive up to three days so you
could see yeah thank you for the
question you can see here on the
stainless steel and plastic that there's
the dashed line is the detectable amount
of virus so you can see that a 72 you
still are a little bit above detection
and then 96 it's undetectable so so a
lot of places a lot of news headlines
will say three days that's true but
that's a that's a three-fold that's a
three log to production so that's a
thousandfold I think it's fair to use
defense what you want to use tenfold or
hundredfold I use tenfold because I
think of transmission risks as
significantly lower once you've had a
tenfold swap question if you don't mind
we know that there is a shortage of
masks in hospitals so if we look at this
data does that mean that if we save the
masks for four days then they can be
reused yes correct
that's right they you know they will
accumulate dust and other things but as
long as you get breathing them easily in
theory you can just set this aside to
mask and wait for days and pick it up
again yes
okay so should I move on yes please all
right so yeah so now that we know how to
kill the virus we might ask how two
stars kill us so as many of you know you
get initial flu-like symptoms
sore throat coffee for an eighth
shortness of breath and for many in fact
probably most people they only have
these symptoms the symptoms onset is 48
days so it starts about a week after
infection in severe cases it will spread
to the lungs and cause pneumonia and
that's shown in the top image so this
this can be diagnosed by CT
a wide variety in symptom severity so
50% about 50% are estimated be
asymptomatic that's based on data from
the diamond princess the ship in Japan
five percents will require
hospitalization and supplemental oxygen
due to difficulty breathing and that 5%
is taken from sort of estimates based on
diagnosed cases of 10% elsewhere
adjusted for the 50%
Aysen rate of asymptomatic presentations
Michael we have some questions if I may
interject so one question is is the
disease severity related to the dose of
virus exposure yeah that's a really good
question I suspect it is I haven't seen
any data because obviously you can't
those people with different amounts of
viruses but I suspect it is perhaps what
happened what might happen is if you get
a lot of virus at once you'll have more
immediate infection of lungs and you
just start off with a higher viral titer
and then your your immune system is
behind in the race and so example this
is the is the doctor who raised the
alarm in hinds name is the when when the
army I think and mmm um yeah it's funny
it's such a sad case every time I say
his name I start crying but on because
he he was only 39 and he died so that
was really unusual um he was treating
multiple patients with the virus so it
probably was because he was breathing a
lot of virus okay a few more questions
Michael so there's one maintain immunity
to the virus if they go through it once
probably I mean there's no data that
suggests that you lose immunity so
almost if it's like any other virus then
it's likely that you are immune I mean
SARS patients have proven to be immune
so I think we should work with that
assumption here
also when you get how long after the
infection will you test positive in
other words you're infected today you
show symptoms let's say eight days from
today at what point will you test
positive yes you will probably test
positive around four days five days yes
these are great questions
so what happens in the course of the
disease is the virus will land in your
throat and I'll start replicating and
it's now a race between your immune
system and the virus so the virus will
you know might double I might well
what's not doubling it's probably as a
probably as a size of several thousand
meaning one cell can put out several
thousand viruses it will do that over
maybe 18 to 24 hours about one day um so
the virus is replicating really quickly
for you to get a positive PCR test you
need to have a swab that gets enough
virus then creates enough nucleic acid
in the reaction and for you for the test
is detected so my guess is that you will
need to have two virus for three to four
days before you have a positive test I
will have one more question and then
we'll pause there there are so many
questions on the chat and I will ask you
one more question we'll come back to
other questions later so you can go on
with your presentation and so the
question is what is known about the
disease severity with hey Jill I was
just reading a question and I lost it
one second I have a question what is
known about its disease severity with
respect to image the alleles is known
about why some people are more or less
susceptible to catching the disease Yeah
right that's a good question um so some
of them might have to do it MHC alleles
as described although right so yeah it
could be that it could be it could be
differences in innate immunity um so
your first your body's first reacting
the virus is to produce cytokines and
and then have cells that are infected by
the virus actually shut down protein
synthesis so that viruses can't
reproduce as quickly so it's kind of
like a fire alarm the first the first
step its that might differ between
people you know you wonder why kids
don't have severe effects from the virus
so perhaps kids have a have a stronger
innate immunity response and it's only a
few days later that your t-cells arrive
at the your T and B cells are activated
and the and the antibodies are produced
by the by your b-cells in sufficient
number to block the spread of the virus
so so the fact that some people come
through it without any symptoms at all
like kids and like 50% of the population
in general might have to do my guesses
has to do with differences in Nate's
community and then how effective you are
in having your adaptive immunity so
that's your t-cells and b-cells that Rex
specifically recognized the proteins on
the virus how successful you are getting
those those working and clearing the
virus we have to do it MHC alleles and
you have to do with how many white blood
cells you have certainly it seems to be
a certainly seems to be a more of a
problem as people get older thank you
we'll pause we'll come back to questions
after we hear more of the talk sure yeah
so so when it gets really bad is when
you need mechanical ventilation and
that's about half the cases that require
hospitalization begin with and then you
know when when people die of the disease
it's due either to direct breakdown of
the alveoli in the lungs and there's a
photo of that in the bottom right or you
have this massive release of cytokines
by your immune cells because now you've
recruited billions of you mean cells
their lungs I'm not trying to fight the
virus and they release a lot of
cytokines which actually can cause low
blood pressure and multi-or
in failure especially kidney failure so
throughout this you know this is a slide
deck that's put that I put on the web
and I have links for all the facts you
know just to make sure the facts are
double-checked and for more information
so if you go to my Twitter feed which is
Michael's Elain all one word Z as in
zebra Michael zeglen
you can download it's a pin tweet you
can download the slide deck from there
in the future if you want to go through
brows or any of these links so yeah it
doesn't make for a pretty presentation
but I think it makes for more
informative document all right so now a
lot of text so whatever one everyone
wants to know is what is the probability
I will get the disease like how many
people have the disease and that's
impossible to know from looking at the
case numbers so this is something where
you know it the news will report the
case numbers it's misleading the case
numbers are always less than the
infection numbers so if you want to know
infection numbers you have to I think
you know we have to go by we have to
estimate the probability of death and
work back from there so how do we know
the probability of death from infections
well you can start with some good data
so you could start with the police has
done the most testing per capita in s
South Korea so right now in South Korea
the well what you see in this in this
graph in the middle is is the number of
cases diagnosed in orange and the number
of deaths is in red so looks like
there's a small number of deaths but
actually we know that deaths on average
lack diagnosis by two weeks and this
means infections by three weeks it's
actually two to three weeks or
infections by three or four weeks
misdiagnosis tends to happen around one
week after infection when the symptoms
first start so if you look at the the
death and
curves the death curves indeed lag the
case curves by about two weeks so this
this case curve as you can see is sort
of flattening out it's reaching sort of
a constant rate of about hundred per day
but the death the death curve looks like
this curve from three weeks ago or two
weeks ago which is right around here so
it's still sort of in this in this
inflection point it hasn't yet doesn't
get flattened out that's the death curve
I was I just mentioned so the current
total deaths occur from cases diagnosed
two weeks or earlier ago so if we have
75 total deaths last week and out of a
out of 4,000 cases two weeks earlier
that's a case fatality rate of about 1.9
percent but we know that infections have
to be at least greater than a number of
diagnosed cases um so that means they're
true infection fatality rate is less
than one point nine percent and it
depends on what fraction infections were
diagnosed at you know two weeks ago so
it's somewhere below 1.9 percent can I
ask you something about that Michael
watching the Johns Hopkins a real-time
cases website and they report that for
the resolv'd quite cases the rate is
more like 10 percent how should we think
about that the closed cases are the
cases that ended either in the patients
being fully recovered or in this yeah
well I think they're just slow to
resolve the cases um it takes about a
month to - if you have a severe case
takes about a month to fully recover
free of symptoms and you know these
these resolution numbers and I'm not
sure how they're done they might be
waiting for people to be for your
symptoms or maybe they just don't follow
up in a large proportion of cases I my
guess is they're not following up it's
just people are too busy dealing with
the new cases too
about what happened to the old ones so
yeah the case closed your numbers
resolution numbers have been low for all
the countries so how else can we get
this IFR is all-important infection
totality rates so an analysis of Chinese
data gave an IFR of 0.5% hmm some people
doubt the reliability of that data I
haven't looked at it myself but analysis
of the diamond princess that's a ship in
Japan again gave one point two percent
as the infection fatality rate now on
the diamond princess some patients may
have been helped with thee with this new
medication REM disappear but also those
passengers were on the old side and we
know it will people are more more
impacted so I think that one point to is
is if air is a sort of a good estimate
also you could look at population
distribution so if you look at the
number of people over 60 there's more in
Korea than in the US and there's more in
the u.s. than in China so so I would
guess that the IFR for the American
population is probably around one
percent so an estimate based on age
adjusted data from China also gave a
very similar number of 0.9% and the
range of point four to one point four so
that shows you the range shows you how
difficult is to really pick a number but
let's just go with one percent all right
the next slide oh I need to click okay
so as everyone knows death is much more
likely for an older population so that's
unfortunately the case it's not that you
know the same is true with flu so it's a
you know it's it's not a surprising fact
but you can see that unlike the fluids
it it seems to be much worse now this is
this again i think is actually death
rates out of total diagnosed cases
without a without a two or three week
time lag so um this might be this might
be actually a little bit of an
underestimation meaning of the
denominator cases might be smaller might
and actually in actuality be smaller
than shown here so this meat this makes
the disease much more severe than food
Michael we have an interesting question
there any reason beyond age distribution
why I farce would be different across
countries so we've heard that in the
u.s. mostly younger people are
experiencing severe disease yeah some
young people experienced severe disease
but I think it's still a small
proportion out of the total infected in
the young people as for I haven't heard
of any I haven't heard of good data for
differences in the age distribution of
severity there certainly will be some
country to country data in countries
where older people are more likely to
smoke they ought to be more impacted so
maybe that's a little bit of a
difference like maybe in South Korea
older people had a smoking history
whereas that's less likely in the US but
there I think we lack the data on that
also can the virus mutates into being
more deadly we've heard that maybe there
are two strains and there are worrisome
numbers in France it's not clear if
there is they're more strains right
there about that yes
can mutate to be more deadly in theory
there's no particular reason to think
that it will get selected for that
though meaning you viruses actually
don't want to kill their hosts too
quickly they'd rather the host stay
healthy and just be coughing a lot so
there's no reason to believe there's no
reason and particularly be very afraid
of that yes right so meaning the virus
is known to be stable it's known to be
you know it's known adapter a bat host
in a stable manner I don't think there's
any reason that it would be selected for
increased increased fatality
so so right so I made an estimate of how
many new cases this is we don't go
through the numbers but basically you
take the current I split up in two weeks
I go over we quite week I take the
number of deaths in the last week and I
multiplied by 100 to get a number of
infections that happened four weeks ago
in the week ending four weeks ago so and
I do this at the end of each week to
update the slide tip so this smooths out
day to day differences in the reporting
of deaths and it also doesn't require
any calculus it's basically a numerical
analysis it's like doing Riemann sums
with a time interval of the week so what
you need to know is sort of the rate of
new infections each week so if there
were for example in California there
were 10 this week and deaths this week
that means there were a thousand new
cases four weeks ago armed with a
doubling time of the infection of seven
days some people estimated six days I
just use seven so we could sort of make
the analysis simpler with a doubling
time of seven days then um from four
weeks ago we can we're now sixteen fold
higher in rate of new infections so
they're probably 16,000 new infections
the last week in California which is 1
in 2,500 people so and then in the area
were more impacted in other regions of
California so I just um I just assume
it's one of thousands of the area now
what can you do or you know your inflate
you're in mount you're in Boston which
is also heavily impacted so it might be
also something like one of the thousand
people just got the virus in the last
week so what does that mean well fifty
percent of people will be asymptomatic
so they'll never know um and this is
based on again the diamond princess data
it's also based on some mathematical
analyses of the Chinese China data and
of data from passengers on evacuation
flights back to us um so fifty percent
of people will never know
yeah Virginia patien is seven days for
the transmission may begin two days
before symptoms so that means a large
portion people will start transmitting
in verse without knowing even if they do
eventually get symptoms so so that means
you have a risk of one thousand from
direct personal contact perhaps and
higher than that from touching objects
that commonly that are commonly touched
which are called for mites those are
things like door handles so in the risk
of touching fomites or contracting if
I'm touching fomites is in proportion to
the number of people touching that
between cleanings so if I you know a
hundred people touch that door handle
before you touch it now that risk is
increased to one in ten so that means we
had to take action to reduce the risk of
acquiring a virus either directly or
from touching so what would happen if we
don't do if we did nothing so obviously
exponential growth will continue with
the doubling time one week and you can
do a quick simple model as shown here
this is very amateur model most of you
can do better models again I didn't want
to do calculus or no equations it's just
it's just doubling and then we reach a
point where we run out of people to
infect and according to this model
that's in late May and California
officials estimate 56% you know total
infections Angela Merkel famously said
seventy percent or something you know
between fifty and seventy percent at
that point a virus runs out of targets
and it's harder for the virus to find
new people to infect everyone else has
been immune so that makes that makes it
the top infection rate about twenty
percent for the last two weeks and then
four weeks after that we'll have deaths
that result from that 20% infection rate
and that's huge
so that would be cute if you accumulated
all the deaths those numbers shown here
at California you have to multiply by
eight to get us that would be 2 million
cumulative deaths ok yeah this is really
just an amateur back-of-the-envelope
calculation but I think it's better than
other back envelope calculations that
you've seen
uses it uses reported death numbers and
this estimated IFR professional models
say a hundred million cumulative
infections that's 30 percent or you know
50 or you could say 56 percent in the
case of the one that was done for
California an estimated IFR of 0.5 as a
conservative estimate so I think my
estimate is is not not too far off it
might be a worst-case scenario would be
the 60 percent and the 2 million but it
could be better and there's some nice
sites for following case numbers and
fatality numbers if you want so compared
to the flu if we're looking at a which
had accumulative infection rate of so
27% and ifr 2% this is this is probably
you know similar in total numbers for
the flu was you know famously
devastating the disease itself is
probably worse now than the flu because
back in 1918 they didn't have
ventilators or drugs or antibiotics so
this is why we need to famously flatten
the curve there are estimated an
estimated five percent will require
hospitalization and 2.5 percent of those
require ICU and ventilation and the
average hospital stay is three weeks so
that means that in the last three weeks
of of May we'll get 10 - 10 20 and 20
percent of the population infected and
then that 4 weeks later in June will
results in 1.6 million 3.2 million and
3.2 million people needing
hospitalization and due to the three
weeks that they need to stay in the
hospital that's eight million
overlapping at the same time compared to
1 million hospital beds so that means we
should slow down the doubling time from
one week to at least eight weeks of
course the slower the better
so that makes the next month critical
and that's why I'm California shutting
down in Boston I think has shut down so
these we need to know how far down we
can get the are not and which is the
reproduction number or increase how much
we get increased the doubling time and
due to the delay between infection and
diagnosis and and hospitalization it
will take us several weeks to know if
it's really working and it's a hard
deadline for this is really early May I
can update the slide I think it's no
longer May 16th I think let me go back I
guess you could say it's around May 15th
it would still be bad but you know won't
require martial law yet but if you got
to May 15th you would have to basically
confine people their their homes by you
know threat of arrest because otherwise
any further infection would would
overflow our medical system
so what can flatten the curve so so I'm
optimistic that weather will help it's
not going to help a lot but it's gonna
help a little bit so based on based on
that that graph from earlier a 10 degree
rise for Fahrenheit in Fahrenheit will
increase the doubling time blowing well
lower the amount of virus survival by
twofold so I think you should you should
I would assume it would increase the
doubling time to fold so actually I I
correct myself a 10 degree change I
think increases the amount of death
tenfold on the bar so these should
increase the doubling time of these two
phone and then it shall also get people
outdoors so keeping them apart so that's
why the flu is seasonal for example um
so the goal is to reduce the
reproductive number or not which is an
you know amount of people infected by
each patient to one point zero or lower
the current rate is estimated to be two
in that infection the the sequential
infection time is interval is about
seven days you know basically starting
from around when shedding occurs at five
days to win to when symptoms start at
seven days so one effect with one person
effects to others in seven days
that would explain a doubling time of
one week so the drop in are not to zero
will make the doubling time infinite and
drops in between one and two will
increase on the doubling time in
proportion to the dropping or not
so you know we have been able in other
countries to drop the r-dog 21.0 to a
constant rate of new cases concentrated
constant very small rate of new cases in
South Korea Taiwan Singapore and Hong
Kong and that's actually without
shutting down the economy that's why
doing social distancing very very robust
testing and tracing very strict hygiene
especially the use of face masks and
very careful what you touch I thought I
wanted to follow up with a couple of
questions from the chat
people are wondering Wuhan was very
successful in flattening their curve why
are the rest of us struggling yeah what
should we be doing more right I think
it's too early to say you know in
California we just implemented a
lockdown on the Tuesday um it will take
in the diamond and the cases are ramping
up so a lot of the increase you see in
the case numbers is just do the testing
and that's probably true even in places
like Italy where they've they've had a
lockdown for a little bit longer so yeah
so you know as a reminder if we're to
get if I was to get infected today I
wouldn't be test a twin show symptoms if
I was to be infected today I wouldn't
and if I were to show symptoms I
wouldn't show symptoms for another five
to seven days and currently there's a
delay in the u.s. testing so it probably
wouldn't be testing tested for another
seven days after that so now there's
this two-week delay between when when
infections start and one testing is
complete so we won't see any change to
the our nods or the doubling time at
least for another two weeks and in fact
most people from from news reports it
seems like most people with symptoms are
being told to stay at home and so it
gets until it gets and to see whether
they get better or worse - basically not
test unless it get worse
and so that means a large proportion of
my cases are being missed right now as
testing expands it expands to those mild
cases or expensive people who are just
household contacts and then that's going
to explode a number of diagnosed cases
so that means we're not gonna see a
reduction by looking at the case numbers
the only way we can see a reduction I
think is looking at the desk number is
because those were actually those will
those will follow the infections by
three to four weeks but that's still a
faster time window than the ramp-up of
the testings appears appears will be
Michael lots of other questions and
activity on the chat let's see can we
can you make a comment about face masks
and yes Asia says you must use face
masks masks is the only way in the u.s.
we're told face masks masks don't help
at all
yes done face masks okay then okay let's
see what is okay one more question what
is the best-case scenario you told us
the worst-case scenario right it's the
best case scenario for recovery yes in
terms of numbers I assume right I mean
the best case scenario for a person and
numbers yeah
yeah all right the best case scenario
for a person is a symptomatic disease
the best scenario for recovery without
vaccines is probably something like the
next line and the slides can get you
which is complete household isolation
Michael for the country for the country
what's the best let's say everyone stays
at home what's the best case scenario
how many more needs to recover from
where we are right so I think if
everyone stays at home it's like me we
can limit the are not to something like
one things here on average
maybe even lower so in wuhan they did
complete household isolation which is
similar to what we're doing now in
California except they probably have
fewer exceptions for vital industries so
in here in California we have exceptions
for mostly of essential essential
industries including hmm marijuana
dispensaries so the but in you know in
will highly a complete house with
isolation mm-hmm and then they took you
know they took infected household
members to central quarantine mm-hmm
locations or or hospitals any practice
strict hygiene in this drop they are not
from three point nine to 0.32 and now
Ohana or China is is reporting no new
cases some people don't doubt that's
actually true but regardless they have a
large drop in the number of cases so if
we practice complete household isolation
then you know the disease would go away
but that's that would that would require
complete stoppage of even essential
industry so I don't think that's likely
in the US but it's possible we can drop
the iron out to something like one and
then once better drugs or vaccine comes
along then then it would be safe a big
fear is uh pre symptomatic or
asymptomatic transmission in in Wuhan
when they took the symptomatic patients
out of their home the are NFL from one
point three to 0.32 so this is just that
only 24 percent or that fraction point
3q over 1.30 transmission events
occurred before symptoms but another
study estimates that forty four percent
of transmission is in the precinct
symptomatic period that's done by
modeling so um you know I'm not able to
evaluate those models or the quality
that data behind those models so I don't
know how good those numbers are but so
but we can you know we can assume
something like 24 percent at forty four
percent and maybe a third of
transmission events occur before before
getting symptoms or without symptoms
so how about completely asymptomatic
patients so the undiagnosed carriers are
estimated me about 50% as infectious as
diagnosed carrier diagnosed cases the
undiagnosed carriers in this study which
is just published in science this week
include people who will eventually get
the disease so that's not completely
asymptomatic but undiagnosed carries a
problem I'm more likely be asymptomatic
than diagnosed ones obviously and 50% of
people get the disease seem to not have
any symptoms at all so this is this
implies that a symptomatic SAR not as
infectious as symptomatic people so go
to next slide yeah so how effective is
this we talked a bit already about the
China South Korea Taiwan Singapore
experiences but you could see that here
on this graph the y axis is log graph is
log scale so that means a line would be
would be exponential growth and so you
can see that some countries are still on
a line like France mmm like Japan
actually in the US but others have have
become stable again this is case number
so some of the initial growth in cases
especially in the u.s. is just from
faster testing so everyone wants to know
if there are drugs so okay this is the
part where I probably will go quickly
because there's this is mostly done for
a biochemical audience but I'll say that
there are a few drugs that have that are
very likely to work so one is this drug
that's already approved in Japan for
pancreatitis
it's an imager of a class of enzymes
proteases that are required for entry of
the virus and what's interesting is it
was tested in cell culture and it has
wide ability to block the replication of
all sorts of corona viruses including
SARS probe 1 and source code 2 and
that's shown here in the bottom left
it's also been tested against the
original SARS virus in mice so it's
always nice to see things tested
mice is the main barrier to a drug being
effective is getting high enough
concentrations in vivo but not having
any toxicity in vivo things that things
that are talked to the humans often show
up in toxicity in mice so it's a good
it's a good proxy for humans so you
could see oh excuse me you can see here
that this drug chemists at reduce the
amount of death from Tsarskoe of one
infection in mice compared to nothing at
all so another one is this is this anti
flute drug called a begun or flatbuki
Revere and this is a drug that gets
converted into a ribonucleoside
which is the building block of RNA and
so then it gets used by the RNA the
virus RNA polymerase and the virus is
now unable to replicate its genome at
least not able to replicate it correctly
the idea is it creates domain mutations
during replication that the virus
eventually fails to replicate so this
again works against the current virus in
human cells and then and then it
actually seems a really poor potency we
use concentration required for a 50%
inhibition as a as a benchmark for
potency this number is actually really
high you usually want it to be below 1
micromolar this is 62 micro molar but
actually you can load this drug to a
high dose in humans 400 micro molar in
your blood which is really high with
just a pill so this is really efficient
and it was declared two days ago to be
effective against the virus and
controlled trials by Chinese Authority
no data was provided so we don't really
know how good the data was what it
sounds promising
this one collector down here is HIV
protease inhibitor was thought that
maybe because the SARS virus also uses a
protease a protease is a enzyme that
cleaves other proteins and it's required
to process one big protein in the virus
to many different parts individual parts
um it was thought that sorry excuse me
it was thought that maybe this HIV
protease inhibitor would be useful and
there was anecdotal experience that it
was it was useful but it turned out just
announced two days ago and I haven't had
time to update the slide and I will
right after the presentation that this
the controlled trial fail and so that
shows the importance of doing controlled
trials and not relying in that on
anecdotal evidence and I always thought
that this I always thought that this
rationale was very weak so I'm not
surprised at the fail
flora coin is getting a lot of press
today and I think it's long overdue
press it was it was it again is shown to
inhibit viral replication of the current
virus and cell culture and a whole month
ago the Chinese health ministry said
that it was superior control treatment
in multiple trials in China but again no
data was shown and I'm not sure why they
don't show data when they make these
announcements it's a little strange to
me I I actually yeah there there's
cynical reasons that they might not be
doing it but for some or they could just
be it could just be a cultural thing but
any case they haven't shown the data but
they said they they made the
announcement that it was useful and then
just two days ago basically the same
conclusion was reached by a French group
they showed that it was effective in
reducing borrow titers in patients an
open-label trial but Clark win in its
relative hydroxychloroquine you're both
similar to both anti-malarial drugs they
do have some side effects so which can
be serious but they have been safely
used for preventing malaria you know I
think it's funny you know it's funny
when the press says always it's not
proven yeah maybe we shouldn't use it
yet like well you don't have to wait for
FDA approval it's already a drug that
you give for malaria prevention
the current disease is a lot worse than
malaria in some respects so I don't see
why we wouldn't just go out and use it
so a joy that gets a lot of press is REM
disappear and that's because it's
probably the most specific of the
current antivirals for SARS co2 7
disappear
it's another pro drug that gets
converted into a ribonucleoside and is
used by the RNA polymerase i was
originally designed to inhibit the RNA
polymerase for another RNA virus Ebola
but it was shown in a published paper to
inhibit the SARS Cove one RNA virus RNA
polymerase and the virus replication in
mice very effectively it also works in
human cells on the on the current virus
and that's not surprising because the
two viruses are 96% identical at the
amino acid level so for you know for
most purposes you can think of SARS Cove
one and two biochemically is essentially
the same and so now it's being testing
humans in multiple trials in the US and
in China the China trial data are due in
a few weeks and it's you know it's
gotten a lot of good anecdotal results
but again we should not rely on that
that's why we have the controlled trials
so there's a lot of text but basically
there as you just know that there are
drugs just to treat the symptoms and not
the virus so death is often from
cytokine release syndrome as we
mentioned and there are drugs for that
and so China has approved one of them
which is a rush antibody against the
cytokine to prevent cytokine release
syndrome there's poor evidence with some
evidence that cox-2 inhibitors that's
just Vioxx and celebrex which were
previously prescribed for arthritis can
prevent so that kind of release syndrome
but no-one's really brought that up
recently again like treating this is
good but it's not as good as preventing
the virus in the first place there's
this big raging debate going on in
medical community about ACE inhibitors
and I hope I'm not we're going to cover
it because I think it's really besides
the point
this is um you know internal medicine
doctors love playing with hypertension
drugs and ASA limiters or hypertension
drugs you know some of you have probably
had three hypertension drugs and this is
just interim medicine doctors live for
doing this stuff and they're fighting
with each other over whether a stew is a
having more or less a stew activity is
good for the virus I think it's a
sideshow they're talking about in
preventing lung injury or decreasing
number of receptors for the virus and I
think it doesn't matter I'm not even
going to touch on it so maybe we're
gonna cover it but anyway there's
there's a link here for more clinical
trials if you're interested so there's a
whole bunch of new things you can make
antibodies from patients or you could
screen antibodies and libraries in vitro
and just produce antibodies that will
bind to the virus so this has already
been announced by two companies there
and Regeneron I'm sure that many more
companies doing this this is a
tried-and-true method this is why when
you somebody's you get a travel shot of
even a globulin before you go traveling
for different viruses so it can be quite
effective and so there also you can also
make more drugs based on the ones I've
already know like like the Deaf flute
drug like the REM disappear and you can
screen for drugs either in vitro or
virtually on a computer so all these
things are being done and then of course
what we really want is a vaccine that we
can give to the entire population in the
fastest right now are these RNA based by
vaccines where they just inject RNA into
your blood and some of it goes inside
your cells and your cells will produce
viral proteins and you will elicit an
immune response to those viral proteins
so there's some more there's a nice for
chemists there's a review of all these
different approaches I wonder why we
don't just fix the virus with from outta
hide and inject it which is how the
first polio vaccine was made by Jonas
Salk and a fixed SARS one vaccine
was found to be protective in monkeys
and this has been proposed for Soros
cliff - it's not like nobody's thinking
about this so I'm guessing it's been
done in China it's been proposed by in
this article that's written by a Chinese
scientist so I'm sure it's been done in
China but you don't hear anything about
this in the US you know the CDC has its
own lab and they used to be we used to
do their own research I don't know if
that's been cut recently but if they're
still doing that it should just be this
is what they should be doing just making
the fastest simplest vaccine and telling
us that they're doing it so that gets me
to the next point which is you know I
okay I should probably skip the film the
many failures of the CDC and the FDA
it's interesting you can read about it I
need to look at the time oh we're out of
time so let's skip this you guys are
interested we are Michael we are still
interested so and we're still here those
of us who can stay online will still
have a few minutes we'd love to hear
yeah we're gonna get a face masks which
is what was asked um so here's a little
table of the symptoms of co vid 19 vs.
the other thing so it's good it's useful
for knowing how it's different from the
code or allergies but basically you
don't tend to have the runny nose or
sneezing but you have all the flu-like
symptoms of a fever cough shortness of
breath headaches leaks so
recommendations for hygiene there many
recommendations but essentially there
are two types so one is the first type
is is being careful to keep the things
you own in your own hands clean so I'm a
liberal user of hand sanitizer so the
alcohol and hand sanitizer will kill the
bacteria so you hear these things like
wash your hands often don't touch your
face like what does it mean how often is
often why can't I touch my face I'm
gonna touch my hit face right now it's
totally fine somebody freaked out the
other day when I did that I'm like my
home everything's clean so basically you
should establish clean zones
this is similar they like if you ever
done surgery on animal or watch surgery
obviously you sanitize before surgery
and then you have a clean zone once your
once everything is clean clean things
can touch other clean things so that
means that you should sanitize your
hands right after touching things that
are touched by others you should
preferably only use between hand to
touch others things other people's
things or handling things to others but
clean your hands again afterwards and
that means also sanitizing objects you
get right so like someone someone drops
off something for you I would actually
sanitize the outside of the package if
it's cardboard I wouldn't worry about it
too much I'll just leave the cardboard
there but if they're giving you a smooth
object like you know yeah like a CD you
know something that I can hold the virus
I would I would wash it and sanitation
means washing with soap or using hand
sanitizer or using Windex or using
bleach and so again if you if you
already have something cleaning your
house you don't to worry you don't keep
on washing it or you don't keep on you
washing your hands when you're home
right so people ask about disinfectants
you know like Lysol or things that have
bleach these are made for large areas
that you don't you can't really soap and
wash or put alcohol on if you can use
soap or alcohol you don't need to also
bleach something like you're not gonna
no one tells you to put your hands in
bleach after you wash them with soap and
water so if you can wash an object with
soap and water you don't need to
quote-unquote disinfect it with a
disinfectant so right so I just keep my
hand to myself as much as possible face
masks short answer is yes so you will
see so in the u.s. we're fond of saying
that they're ineffective or that you
shouldn't buy them because caregivers
need them but both of those statements
cannot be true simultaneously if they
were ineffective and the caregivers
would not meet them so they are
effective so the block 95% of viruses if
worn properly and that's because viruses
are carried in droplets and they
basically the masks are
filters so you know they're these
there's a study done between surgical
masks which is their simplest reply
masks that look like they're made out of
paper in cloth and then there's the the
cup-like masks the n95 respirators the
study said they're actually similarly
effective but the n95 respirators are
thought to be more effective so my
recommendations for masks use are based
on relative risks the reason we've been
told not to use them is to save them for
the caregivers and because the risk that
you'll run into somebody who's emitting
virus in public is very low so basically
one in a thousand at the moment so if
you're just walking by yourself in
public you'd be wasting a mask but I
think they would be useful when you're
close you're in proximity with strangers
so when you're writing in an airplane a
train and a burl if because you don't
know the driver might be contagious and
especially if you're going to go to a
hospital or clinic so what about the
store yeah so depends how proud of the
store is I avoid store so I don't know
how proud of they are but I think if
you're going point it I would have a
mask ready if you go to go to
supermarket and you see that you have to
be waiting in line I would put on a mask
and then if you're immuno compromised or
you're elderly it's probably a good idea
to put on the mask anytime you're in
public just in case the guy who's
jogging by you reads on you so so once
the infection rates climb and it's
useful for everybody in public so and
then they're absolutely recommended if
you're sick because they block the clock
the acceleration of viruses from a sick
person so again the only controversy of
masks is due to its limited supply but I
think people are wising up to this the
former FDA Commissioner is Scott
Gottlieb just tweeted his support for a
mask use so I think you can only tonight
effects were so long so this is sort of
an example of public health officials
giving people partial information that's
deliberately misleading so I think
they've been disingenuous
and it's caused people to lose trust in
them you know they they should just be
honest that people are adults if you
tell them masks are effective but the
rate of infection right now is so low
and we don't have enough mass to go
around that we'd like you not to use
them not to buy them that makes complete
sense but telling people you shouldn't
use them because they're not effective
for you it's true but it's true only in
a very misleading sense and it doesn't
engender trust when people find out the
full truth so you just need some
filtration so if you don't my mask and
the guy next to you is coughing then
just put your I'll just put your nose
into your sleeve and breathe through
that I mean I do that when I go to the
bathroom anyway and no you know from
experience that that blocks odors so it
must be filtering something in fact a
study shows that it's shared block 70%
of our size particles so that makes
sense so I won't go into this how to use
mass and how to conserve masters I think
most people just want to know whether
it's a good idea or not but I would say
that in Asia like in Taiwan and South
Korea China and Japan it's it's not just
okay it's expected that you wear masks
and in mainland China it's required that
you wear masks in public so even if they
have a great reflection rate they have
enough masks to go around yes Michel for
what's worse we're trying to mobilize
our alumni network to help us with masks
because I think that's your right oh
yeah I mean the US you know I mean the
u.s. is is increasing manufacturing your
masks but it's still slow at the moment
relative to me so the washable masks are
not as good as the n95 but they're still
good with a certain surgical masks and
n95 masks are equally on washable
there's cloth masks that you can buy
like allergy masks and again they're
probably better than nothing well
they're not as good as surgical masks
which are the three ply you know
flexible ones and then or that cup-like
n95 masks but on this slide i say that
you can I suggest decontaminating it by
heating it up in the oven for 70 degrees
Celsius for 30 minutes
or putting it putting them a UV
sterilizer well as we mentioned before
if we just let them sit in a clean place
for for a week the virus should be dead
so um I have a list of things that I
think are okay to do like visiting
relatives if you're really careful with
the hygiene steps but I would you know I
would definitely recommend buying
groceries online instead of in the
grocery store you know you could say
well the person would pick some package
ago so you might be infected
but that same is true in a grocery store
the person who stocks the items on the
shelf is has the same chance of being
infected Plus in the grocery store you
have a thousand other shoppers going
through and then the cashier has to
touch you know touch the goods that a
thousand other shoppers have have
selected and touched so it's better just
reduce the number of those interactions
and just buy your groceries online if
you can but that's about it so you know
travel if necessary I think if you're
armed with this so if you're armed with
some hand sanitizer mask you can travel
just be careful with you know with
keeping your hands clean keeping your
space clean and I would just end with
this that because 50% of people with
virus have no symptoms but will become
immune and because that means 95 percent
of people don't go to hospital
most people get the disease will recover
at home in about a week the workforce is
not threatened so you know there will be
enough farmers and truck drivers and
store workers to distribute food and
sell food so you don't have to go out
and buy everything in sight so that's
about it and in the next slide as you
guys are seeing online there's a there's
the recipe for how to make your own
Henson attend so if you're not able to
buy any out of just ethanol or
isopropanol and glycerol so that's it so
I'm sorry to take so long oh this has
been fantastic thank you so much for
taking time for us I
do you have a couple minutes for a few
more questions or okay so we don't want
to impose on your time but we do have a
couple of questions actually we have a
lot of questions let me just pick on a
few can you talk about the possibility
of reinfection yeah you mean like any
and infected again after you've cleared
it yes I think it's small you know there
was this it was his worry that was
because a woman had recovered from the
virus and then in the left a hospital
with a negative test and then got worse
and got a positive test and it was taken
as evidence that you could clear the
virus and get reinfected but it's
probably just the negative test was
negative I mean she probably was
fighting a virus pretty well but then
the virus rebounded so it's more like a
case of just insufficient you mean
response to the virus to begin with but
if she cleared it the second time and is
really clear then it should be fine
your memory you know your your B and T
cells take a week to ramp up and but
then your your long live memory these
cells take something like a month to to
differentiate so there's this it has to
do with the switching of the types of
IgE so there might be a you know there
might be this window where the virus can
come back but it's not because you it's
less likely that you're getting
reinfected from outside as just a
low-level infection inside so along
similar lines what can you share about
the possibility of recovering the summer
and fall all the students return to
school and then we have a recurrence
that's even worse than what we have now
yeah so I think one thing that public
officials are not saying yet well they
don't know what's gonna happen but is
that you know these kinds of measures
are going to have to be kept in place
until a vaccine is a vaccine or a very
very effective treatment is is made and
so you know the RNA vaccine so
probably will probably know if they're
if they're useful in in six months but
then it might take you know I might take
another few months to to ramp up
production and distribution so we're not
likely to be in time for a September
vaccination these drugs like chloroquine
run disappear you know clerk clean you
don't want to really dose to everyone
it's too toxic for that when destiny you
might dose it to high-risk populations
and disappear is likely to be in short
supply is probably only 50% effective
anyway and so you don't want to rely on
the drugs too too much entirely what are
what are the barriers to manufacturing
these drugs faster and in larger
quantities chlorine is no barrier is
very simple
[Music]
the feffy peer review also looks pretty
simple I'm pretty sure they can be
manufactured for millions of people but
it's it's probably the side effects are
probably such that you don't want to
take it if you unless you really have to
the yeah and then run disappear it looks
more complicated that's probably harder
to synthesize but Gilead is is upping
the simplest helping the production but
again these drugs are not going to cure
everyone of disease and so they're more
like less they're more like
hospitalization medicine so they're only
for the 5% of people go to the hospital
and then some only maybe only 50% of
those who take the drug will will still
be able to fight it off and that's just
that's just a guess at the moment maybe
e 75% so it's still going to be a burden
on the hospitals unless we unless we
continue to be careful what I would like
to see is us to be turning the work
would just be more careful like people
are in Asia I think it's a public
education problem you know in the US the
county the the local authorities don't
even bother trying a course of education
before
course of lockdown because
is they seen how people don't react to
the two proclamations you know keeping
you know staying away from crowded
places so but you know in Asia you can
do it people may be much more just much
more scared
viruses more used to working in entites
environments
you see used to things like wearing a
face mask in and sanitizing spaces can
you also address briefly the testing
bottleneck and what we can do to test
more I am I admire how Korea tested so
many people and and they have tests
that's come around in 15 minutes I hear
what I hear yeah I don't know yeah I'm
not sure about the 50 minute test I
really don't know maybe there it is but
that would be amazing
what I want to hurt what I saw in
articles about Korea is that they first
of all the companies took so their own
initiative develop tests early and then
the Health Ministry coordinated was many
companies to roll out multiple tests at
once because they knew it might be a big
thing they wanted to be ready um you
know Korea gets a lot of a lot of
visitors from China so they probably
suspected they would get a lot of
infections from China in the end you
know they got most of their infections
from one patient patient 31 who you know
who infected people through her church
so but they were ready for that you know
in the u.s. part of it is the federal
nature of the government the Korea still
a relatively small country of 40 million
people so what's okay so what's funny is
you know when China locked down Wuhan in
the province of Hebei that was 50
million people and I just read an
interview by my doctor thought she where
he was asked would that ever happened in
u.s. is I know that's impossible we
could never do that so now we've locked
California's 40 million people to size
of Korea so so we so it's possible to do
it but in in the u.s. we have 320
million in the federal government
so it's and as we know we have a federal
government government that's been
onestart the resources and to
ideologically reluctant to to spend a
dime on on any public on any public good
so it's it's just a complete failure of
our political system well I mean let's
be honest it's a complete failure of one
set of people in charge
Michael you have a lot of captive
computer scientists and engineers on
this call
what can computing an engineering do to
help with this difficult moment in time
yeah that's a good question not being a
computer scientist myself I you know I
don't want to give advice I think you
know you guys are you guys will you guys
will figure it out you know it's no
making making cheap ventilators is
certainly one possible solution you know
using computer science to to work with
biologists to screen for drugs or
analyze genomes is another possible
solution yeah I think yeah I think talk
to your colleagues you know talk to your
colleagues in biology it's harder to do
that now that we can't gather in the
cafeteria but you know we'll have a few
weeks of being at home you know it's
possible to to urge your department
chairs to to send messages to their
other colleagues in other departments
asking if anyone needs any assistance in
their research efforts Michael thank you
so much if you get any computational
challenges please reach out to us we
would be loved we would love to help and
really appreciate you sharing your time
and your knowledge with us thank you
clap on behalf of everyone well thank
you very much yeah appreciate your time
thank you so much
okay signing off thank you hi everyone
thank you for joining us I hope you
enjoyed the presentation and you learned